Back in the early 2000s, Hayden Panettiere
was everywhere. From her role in the popular
series Heroes to plum parts in rom-coms like
I Love You, Beth Cooper, she made her rounds
in Hollywood. For all that exposure, however,
Panettiere has largely faded from public view.
Panettiere rose to mainstream prominence
by starring as Claire Bennet on Heroes.
For a while, the show was enormously
popular and uniquely headline-making,
something of a predecessor to the ever-expanding
world of TV series we know today. Those who were
around for its burst of success will
likely recall its infamous tagline,
"Save the cheerleader, save the world."
Claire Bennet is this very cheerleader,
and was featured prominently in the show's
promotional campaigns. Claire has
the power of cellular regeneration,
which allows her to heal quickly
from injuries and become practically
immortal. When she initially discovers her
powers, she's both curious and frightened,
and eventually realizes that her own fate
might be tied to that of the entire world.
Heroes didn't just earn the public's
acclaim — critics initially responded to
it with glowing praise as well. The first
season inspired widespread excitement,
scoring multiple wins and nominations
from a wide variety of industry awards,
including the Golden Globes and the Emmys. But in
later seasons, Heroes' ratings took a tumble. It
began to feel as though the writers had no real
plan for giving the show a satisfying conclusion,
and the narrative became increasingly ludicrous
and convoluted. Unfortunately for Panettiere,
Heroes has become remembered for its stellar
first season and not much else. In the end,
the show was canceled on a low note, which very
well might have impacted Panettiere's career.
When Panettiere started her career as a
child actor, she worked on soap operas,
television movies, and the occasional miniseries.
Disney came calling in the late 1990s,
leading to her roles as Dot in A Bug's
Life and Suri in Dinosaur. Soon after,
she landed a memorable role in the football hit
Remember The Titans. As she got older and made a
name for herself on Heroes, Panettiere found swift
and dazzling success — but it came with a price.
She quickly found that she was being typecast.
She had already played a talented ice skater
and high school student in Ice Princess, and
now she was playing a cheerleader on Heroes.
She also starred as a cheerleader in both
Bring It On: All or Nothing and I Love You,
Beth Cooper. A theme was developing, and
she wanted out. She told Contactmusic :
"If I don't get out of this category
pretty quickly, it will just get more and
more difficult to be seen as anything besides a
cheerleader. [...] Like ... you get in a corset,
it's hard to get out of a corset again."
As fans of Nashville know, Panettiere is
one heck of a talented singer. But somehow,
her real-world music career never really
got off the ground. Panettiere made her
way down the early sections of the
Disney actress-to-pop star path,
recording songs for several Disney movies
including Ice Princess and Cinderella III:
A Twist in Time. She even started working on her
own album, releasing a single entitled "Wake Up
Call" in 2008. But she wasn't happy with the music
that her record label was pushing her to sing, and
has since revealed her dissatisfaction with this
release. She said in an interview with Vulture:
"At that point I was a puppet,
basically. It wasn't me."
However, these unpleasant experiences in the music
industry have proved useful to her as an actress.
While playing Juliette, an aspiring singer
and one of the main roles on Nashville,
Panettiere took her experiences
into account as her character
was encouraged to record music
she was not passionate about.
"When I read this script and
it became that for Juliette,
I was like, I understand. I know what that is."
Though things ended positively in this regard,
she doesn't think she'll try to record another
album in the future, as she feels that people
will conflate her music with her character.
After having her daughter Kaya in December
2014, Panettiere found herself struggling
with postpartum depression. She sought treatment
multiple times, ultimately checking into a Utah
treatment center for support in May 2016. She
has repeatedly chosen to share her struggles,
as she believes greater openness about the
condition can help other women who suffer
from the condition. In an interview
with Good Morning America, she said:
"It takes you a while and you feel off,
you don't feel like yourself. [...]
Women are so resilient and that's
the incredible thing about them."
She went on to say:
"I think I'm all the stronger for it. I think I'm
a better mom because of it because you
never take that connection for granted"
Today, Hayden's daughter Kaya lives with
her father, former boxer Wladimir Klitschko
in Ukraine. Naturally, she still wants to spend
as much time with her daughter as possible,
so she travels to Ukraine whenever she gets
the chance. It's easy to imagine this might be
a big part of why Panettiere doesn't always
have the free time to commit to new roles.
Although they've been separated for several years
now, Panettiere and Klitschko enjoy a genuinely
amicable bond, and seek to set a positive
example for their daughter. She told Us Magazine:
"We're still respectful of each other,
and we still have that friendship with
each other. [...] It's not a situation
that you find yourself in all that often,
so it's a new one. But I think
we've done a really good job."
It may seem contradictory to say
that a celebrity like Panettiere is
actually a very private person, but that's the
truth. Unlike so many highly visible stars,
Panettiere makes a point of not making every
detail of her life public. While she does share
her struggles with fans when she's ready,
like her battle with postpartum depression,
she rarely posts on Instagram or
Twitter. It's a far cry from the
ultra-connected world of many stars, who have
multiple feeds updating on an hourly basis.
It seems that Panettiere chooses to stay
out of the public eye to the fullest extent
she can these days — and it's not necessarily
because of a lack of opportunities.
While plenty of celebrities enjoy sharing
their day-to-day lives on social media,
Panettiere has strong boundaries
when it comes to privacy.
As Panettiere tried to move forward in her career
and break away from her "cheerleader" image,
she took on a majorly controversial role. In 2011,
she starred as Amanda Knox, the college student
who was convicted of the murder of Meredith
Kercher, in Amanda Knox: Murder on Trial in Italy.
In the real world, Knox was eventually exonerated
when another man was identified as the murderer,
and has since spoken openly about her ordeal.
Kercher's family was unhappy with the contents
of the film, especially because it depicts
a fictionalized version of Kercher's murder.
John Kercher, Meredith's father,
said in an interview with Time:
"It's so awful what these film people have done.
Your imagination runs riot as it is about what
happened, but to actually see it like this is
very different and very distressing. I was told
the original brief and synopsis of the film was
to take it up to the point of the killing but
not actually show the killing itself. It's obvious
from these pictures they are showing the killing."
While Panettiere may have had good
intentions when she accepted the role,
it's clear that this film was deeply upsetting
for those who lived through these events.
After she began working on Nashville, Panettiere
decided to pack up and move to the city for which
the show is named. She purchased a home in
Nashville, and subsequently realized that
she was much happier living there instead of
in New York City or Los Angeles. She felt like
she could be more laid-back, and more true to
herself. Moreover, she told Southern Living that
appreciated that her new neighbors seemed to value
the little things in life, allowing her to slow
down and stop focusing on the non-stop hustle of
life in the entertainment industry. She continued:
"The people here are amazing. Living in
Nashville gives me a sense of normalcy
that I wasn't sure I was ever going to get
back in my life. When I first got here,
all my defenses were still up, and I was
waiting for that world to suddenly creep back
in. When it didn't, I realized that
I can live a normal life here with
people who don't judge you based on what
you do or who you are in the public eye."
Recently, Panettiere has opened up about her
struggle to leave an abusive relationship.
In the summer of 2020, her ex-boyfriend, Brian
Hickerson, was arrested on several charges of
domestic abuse. Now, Panettiere is
speaking out about what happened,
and why she hopes her story can help other
people who are in similar situations break free:
"I am coming forward with the truth about
what happened to me with the hope that
my story will empower others in abusive
relationships to get the help they need
and deserve. I am prepared to do my part to
make sure this man never hurts anyone again."
Now, she's focusing on herself and rebuilding
her life. For Panettiere, stepping away from the
camera for a while has been necessary: After
going through such a traumatic experience,
she wants to put her health and wellbeing
first. Healing has to take priority. Happily,
she has found the courage to speak out and
has surrounded herself with supportive people.
Panettiere is well-known for her activism,
particularly in regards to animal
welfare. After appearing on Heroes,
she realized that she could use her new
platform for good. She told Teen Vogue:
"The show put me in a place to speak for
the things that I'm passionate about."
Panettiere joined up with the Whaleman
Foundation in 2007 to protest dolphin
hunting. She was personally involved in a
confrontation between a group of fishermen
and several surfers in Japan, who had
arrived to protest the annual dolphin hunt
in Taiji. This incident is explored in the 2009
documentary The Cove, which analyzes this annual
dolphin hunt and offers viewers a call to
action for the welfare of these animals.
Today, Panettiere still serves as a
spokesperson for the Whaleman Foundation.
She told Conde Nast Traveler in an interview:
"I'm an activist who's aware of what's
realistic to achieve and what's not.
The Whaleman Foundation's goals] are
achievable, and they make sense."
It goes without saying that this
level of devotion to a cause would
hinder any actress' ability to remain
steadfast in Hollywood's spotlight.
In 2018, the final episode of Nashville aired,
ending Panettiere's six year run as Juliette
Barnes. Since then, she has not appeared
in any other television shows or movies.
Currently, she does not have much
in the way of future roles lined up,
either. At this point, it looks like Panettiere
is purposefully enjoying a well-earned hiatus,
and that she does not have any immediate
plans to get back in front of the camera.
Considering everything Panetierre has gone
through over the course of the past decade,
it's easy to see why she feels the need to
take some time off from acting. She's welcomed
a daughter, battled postpartum depression,
and spoken out about abuse — that's enough
to push anyone to the brink. But she has
not made any statements about retiring,
meaning she'll likely be back on screen in
the future. In the meantime, fans of her work
will be waiting to see what her next move is.
There's no denying her talent: When Panettiere
does decide to act, sing, or campaign again,
she'll certainly enjoy a warm welcome back.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.